Paul Joseph Watson is an author in the
editor-at-large of infowars.com and
prison planet comm Paul welcome to the
Rubin report hi Dave good to be here
glad you are here when we were talking
before we started you were saying that
I'm gonna get I'm gonna get some hate
for this are you warning me of pre hate
I think you've probably already got some
hate just for announcing that I'm gonna
be on I mean there's a lot of people who
have some kind of bought her over
you know Infowars and alex jones they
think is you know just conspiracy
central but most people don't realize
that you know alex is not this big main
controlling force that is like dictating
what everybody says you pretty much
gives me free rein to talk about
whatever I want and that's what's good
about Infowars it's a very broad church
so you've got you know numerous writers
commentators who work with him for wars
and they both can basically talk about
and write about whatever they want so as
far as I'm concerned that's the best job
imaginable so I think people need to get
over it and move on because the issues
that we're talking about supersede any
perception about what Infowars is about
what people think it's about so you know
I just want people to listen to what
I've got to say and concentrate on the
issues rather than you know what website
is hosted on that's irrelevant at the
end of the day right and that's exactly
what happened I mean I just sent one
tweet out this morning saying that you
were coming on the show and immediate ah
conspiracy theorist he works with Alex
Jones and it's like you guys are having
conspiracy theories about the conspiracy
theory so I was like you know let's just
talk it out and we'll see what happens
right no it's it's not as bad as it used
to be I mean I know there's this
perception out there that you know
Infowars is discredited or whatever but
I mean we're breaking stuff every day
we're linked on the Drudge Report
you know we've got 20 million listeners
a week now for the radio show so whether
you like it or not we're a presence and
you know that's why some people have a
problem with it as I said just
concentrate on the issues of what I'm
saying
and in fact my youtube channel explores
these kind of issues off on a tangent
from the normal content that Infowars
would cover so I've kind of
to the new satellite audience outside of
Infowars so it's all about bringing new
people in and that's why I've attempted
to do that's why I think I've been
successful recently
yeah and it's your YouTube channel that
actually got me familiar with what you
were doing because you did a phenomenal
video on the regressive left which
everyone knows I'm not a fan of them
you've done some really interesting
stuff about the European immigration
crisis so yeah we're going to get into
all the issues stuff but just to wrap up
the the Infowars part of this how did
you get involved with Infowars what's
your relationship like with Alex let's
go down that route for a little bit well
I mean I start my own political website
when I was about 18 years old so you
know I would go home and host a radio
show on dial-up internet to three people
to three listeners you know back in the
early 2000s so that was the very genesis
of Alex liked what he was doing he liked
the content I was covering so he
basically had hunted me and said you
know coming in coming at Infowars coming
right for us and that's that's what
happened so now I'm based in London
they're based in Austin Texas so I'm up
you know six hours ahead of time so I
can get a jump on the news that's always
beneficial with the news organization
sure so that's why it kind of works and
he lets me write and say what I want
he's not this controlling presence and
you know a lot of people think that Alex
Jones is a kind of act that it's put on
this radio personality that he has but
if you meet him any hanging around with
him what you see is what you get that's
Alex Jones he's like that all the time
it's not an act he's not putting it on
you know in private in person he's kind
of more jovial and fun than his rants on
the radio would suggest but that's him
that's his personality it's not an act
yeah I'm curious were you trepidatious
to join forces with him because
obviously it was a good opportunity and
saying that it's worked for you but
because of what I said before about I
just send one tweet out and people start
yelling at me you must have had some
level of concern right well that was
that was a long time ago back in the day
so really Alex was only a few years into
his operation true I mean I built up at
a good deal of traffic with my own
website so there was no
predation it was just about reaching a
wider audience so obviously I jumped at
the opportunity yeah so where do you
actually consider yourself politically I
think I have a good sense and one of the
things we've been talking about here is
sort of this new growing center people
who really want to stand up for free
speech and civil liberties but also
understand that we have real threats and
that this immigration issue in Europe is
a big problem they want to be able to
honestly talk about Islamism so the old
dynamic of right/left Democrat
conservative for us in the States it all
seems to be crumbling so I'm curious
what do you even consider yourself if
you had to go at the label um while I
grew obviously when I was a teenager I
was a progressive and I think it was
Winston Churchill that said if you're
not a liberal when you're young you have
no heart if you're not conservative when
you get older you have no brain Roe at
the moment in my 30s I would consider
myself mainly a libertarian maybe you
could call me a conservator Ian but it's
somewhere within that gap between the
two so that's basically where I'm at
right now yeah do you find that movement
growing where you are because I do sense
it's growing here you know our politics
have gotten so crazy between a
Democratic Socialist who's the hot guy
on the left and Trump who's sort of off
the rails but confute you know it is he
really a Republican does he really stand
for conservative values or is he truly a
centrist none of it makes sense anymore
are you guys getting some of that
feeling - um to some extent yeah but I
mean in the UK it's still extremely
left-wing I mean even even the Tory
party isn't classically conservative
they're somewhat left on a lot of issues
so most people don't even know what a
libertarian is in the UK to be honest
only people who are really politically
active will know what that actually
means so I think America is streets
ahead in the sense of actually
understanding that there is a political
alternative outside of progressivism
which is still what dominates the entire
discourse in the UK I mean people will
think you're racist or a bigger if if
you're not progressives especially as a
young person yeah so the circles in
which I move there's very little
understand
about what these labels even mean which
is why I tried to concentrate on the
issues without you know coming at it
from a left or right persuasion yeah and
that's very much what I tried to do and
I've tried to define a lot of these
terms and you know the whole libertarian
ideology really fits with me you know
anything like do with your body what you
want let the government stay out of your
life for the most part and build a life
that works for you but you're saying
that that the idea of that is really
gone in the UK now I don't think I don't
think it was ever here really I don't
think people came to grips with it yeah
I mean there's still there's still some
debate within libertarian circles about
certain issues like abortion or like
open borders I mean some libertarians
think that to be truly classically
libertarian you have to advocate open
borders other people say well no that's
the government foisting open borders
upon the people you know taking their
tax money to pay for it but I mean
within the UK as far as I'm concerned in
my experience these these labels aren't
even known they're not even defined so
when you describe yourself as a
libertarian people have no frame of
reference so they think if you're not a
liberal then you must be on some obscure
fringe of the political spectrum but you
know I guess that the understanding is
growing especially with the backlash
against social justice warriors which is
really accelerated in the past 18 months
so now these issues are beginning to be
brought to the fore now people are
beginning to understand that
libertarianism is a backlash against
authoritarianism which of course is
embodied by this feminist third wave
feminist social justice warrior Minh
yeah you're you're hitting all the buzz
words there so do you think it's really
like just a branding issue for
libertarians because there's sort of no
unifying principle that's bringing us
together other than do what you'd like
and don't harm someone so they just need
sort of better there are good reps
basically or at least from what I see in
the United States we have a couple Gary
Johnson former governor of New Mexico
had on the show and he's running for
president but it's hard to gain traction
when you're one of the outsiders yeah I
think the problem
with libertarianism is there not on the
frontier of political discourse so when
you get major issues that crop up in the
news media obviously as somebody who's
politically active you have to seize
upon them and tell your story and try
and control change that narrative as
best you see fit but libertarians tend
to get stuck in the weeds you know
they're always arguing with each other
about these my new shirt issues and
they're not really on the frontier of
the cultural discourse which is more you
know now the domain of of conservatory
ins and people who oppose social justice
warriors so I think in America the
libertarian movement is still so stuck
in the weeds and arguing you know my new
ship between themselves that they're not
really a robust force as they could be I
think that's one region in which they
could improve by you know hijacking
these key issues these core issues like
the migrant crisis and they're not doing
that they're they're debating with each
other over you know what Minik ism is
and whether we should have no government
or limited government and they have
speeches and three-hour u-tube
conversations about that and they're not
really reaching anyone outside their
inner circle so I think that's how you
know libertarianism needs to improve in
that way right so I guess the the silver
lining to all of this is that because of
the social justice warrior thing and now
we can get into some of these issues is
they're starting to push people into
this idea of libertarianism which is
nice so let's let's go to the social
justice warrior stuff you are not a fan
of the social justice warrior movement
to put it mildly when when did you wake
up to it when did you really see it as
as a threat to free speech I think is
probably mid 2014 I mean I was I was
mainly covering geopolitical issues back
in 2012-2013 I was mainly on you know
the Syrian civil war the build up the
arms race that the confrontation with
Russia over the course of 2013 to 2014
and then I became more active on Twitter
and it's only when you become act
on Twitter and you have to actually put
some time into it and follow the
discourse that's taking place on Twitter
that you realize that these issues are
important because it's no longer just
you know demented 14 year olds on tumblr
expressing their bizarre arcane
grievances these people are in the
Universities they are our future thought
leaders they're being coddled they're
being protected by professors at these
major universities so it was that
connection between realizing that this
is not just idiots with an opinion on
Twitter which is completely obscure this
is now a really robust driving narrative
with it amongst Millennials and that's
once you realize that once you realize
how it's how it's you know infested the
core of the education system in America
and now in Britain as well that to me
really symbolized how important it was
to oppose these people because they
oppose everything I stand for you know
within the tenets of libertarianism
itself yeah you know it's interesting
because I had very similar probably
around the same time
awakening about this because it was a
lot on Twitter right because you're
seeing this stuff on Twitter and you see
the you know the stuff from tumblr that
makes its way over and all these people
fighting about this stuff now we hear
about the trigger warnings and the safe
spaces and all this stuff but I could
never really figure out how much of this
just existed for people behind computers
but basically what you're saying is that
there's been this has been a long time
coming and that's what sort of has
seeped into the university space right
right and now it's becoming really
physical I mean you've seen the Bernie
Sanders people and we're going to get
into the whole Trump thing later but
we've sent our reporters out to
Wisconsin this past week for example and
you know it's not just Bernie Sanders
supporters it's leftists in general
they're the most vile hateful people you
could ever wish to me I mean the sheer
hatred that they give you they radiates
from their eyes when you so much as
disagree with them is palpable and now
they're out there they're shutting down
these private functions these Donald
Trump events which
whether you agree with Trump or not
that's not your free speech First
Amendment right to shut down a private
function you're impinging on other
people's First Amendment by doing that
and these people wave signs saying you
know oppose hatred oppose bigotry
they're the most hateful people you
could imagine so that's what I see now
the translation from Twitter now they're
getting out on the streets of course
we've seen that with black lives matter
that metastasized into a similar hateful
violent movement and we might get into
that later but yet it's it's manifesting
physically now and it's why people are
worried about civil unrest and riots
quite frankly because these people are
prone to violence and they're very
hateful people so okay so we're going to
get into all of that so but you hit on a
lot of things there so one of the things
that I've been saying is I can't believe
we're at a place in 2016 in America
where I fear that it will be us
ourselves the citizens who will take
away our right to free speech more than
the government so in other words it's
not a First Amendment issue in these
people protest because it's not the
government doing it but we do have a
certain social contract that you have to
let people speak and then you can use
their your speech to counteract it but
basically you're saying by blocking
roads and by stopping people from
speaking that that's where it becomes a
free speech issue not necessary right
you see that distinction no I've got no
problem with people being out on the
street protesting I mean that's their
rights when they actually go into Donald
Trump events in private buildings where
they've paid to hire this building and
they get the event in Chicago Council
for example that's impinging on other
Pitt other people's rights to peaceably
assemble exercise their First Amendment
and just listen to somebody speech but I
mean as you touched on before it's this
whole idea of you know before the power
was in the media and we're going to talk
about the media later now it's it's kind
of divested back into the hands of
people it's people power but it's people
power gone mad so now you have organized
groups of people who go out to publicly
shame others to get them fired to censor
content from the
Internet and that's how Twitter in one
sense empowered the people but it gave
that power to these perpetually outraged
mobs and that's what woke me up to the
social justice warrior issue because as
he said it the concern for me a few
years ago was the state the government
impinging on our free speech rights
now it's perpetually professionally
outraged mobs impinging on our free
speech rights I think that's the bigger
danger right now in 2016
yeah I mean listen to anything that the
state's gonna do I completely agree it's
so ironic I can't even think of an
example right now in America where the
state is holding the First Amendment
hostage I can't find one instance where
you can't say whatever you want about
the government or about government
officials or anything like that but I
can see many instances where the mob and
the online mob and they'll try to stop
your patreon funding if you're a
youtuber or they'll try to figure out
other ways to have you fired or shamed
or whatever else do you think that these
people like for example when Trump was
doing the rally in Arizona and and they
blocked the road in Arizona do you think
that they thought that they were helping
their cause because I get it that not
all of these people are thinking all
their moves through properly and they
know they're going out we're going to
stop them from showing up and that's all
good but to me all they really do is
strengthen Trump because then look
nobody that didn't get there is suddenly
not going to vote for Trump it makes
them wanted vote for Trump more and
everyone watching it on the news is
going wow who's being oppressed here
it's actually Trump so it's really it's
fascinating right now I mean I don't
know if they've got any idea of how
ridiculous they look but they've got
this media narrative backing them up
which is that Trump is inciting violence
and this is something that I've been hot
on again I don't agree with Trump on
everything I'm not a vehement trump
supporter but if you go on Twitter on
any single day and search for
assassinate Trump or kill Trump you will
find hundreds and hundreds of examples
obviously most people don't mean it
they're not going to do anything but
they're threatening to assassinate Trump
and yet the whole media narrative is
about how Trump supporters of violent
about how Trump himself is inciting
violence there's a rap video on YouTube
right now and we complain about you know
Twitter censoring conservatives for
having the wrong political opinion
there's a guy who's still on Twitter his
account hasn't been touched by the trust
and Safety Council he's got a YouTube
video which calls for caving Trump's
head in with a shovel shooting him with
an ak-47 filling him full of bullets
it's not even age restricted on YouTube
I mean I've had videos age-restricted
for swear words right and the media came
out afterwards this is a rap video
however I think it's out of Baltimore
and billboard.com celebrated it as quote
a powerful protest song this is a group
of young men in a rap video threatening
to kill Donald Trump imagine if no the
Oregon militia or whoever had come out
with a video threatening to assassinate
Hillary Clinton do you think the media
would be celebrating it as a powerful
protest song so it's that double
standard they're given left media cover
because we've got this narrative that
Trump's inciting violence when again
they're the most hateful violent people
out there well it's so fascinating
because as you've repeated several times
now you're not even a huge Trump
supporter and yet you're you are put in
a position where you have to defend some
of these ideals I'm not a trump
supporter and I feel the same way if I
want to stand up for the ideals that I
stand for I have to call this nonsense
out because apparently no one in the
medial do it you know there's another
great example of that did you see a
couple weeks ago when that guy tried to
bum rush Trump on stage and then the
next night he was on CNN and all the
news channels and they were treating him
as if he was some legit voice of counter
protest but meanwhile he was trying to
attack a presidential candidate whether
you like Trump or not right so this is
this is fully the fault of the media
here right well exactly I mean you flip
around if a right winger tried to attack
Bernie Sanders or Hillary Clinton but he
wouldn't be on CNN the next day being
given a complimentary welcoming platform
yet we see this again and again and you
know Trump is
creation of social justice worries at
the end of the day every action has an
equal and opposite reaction and people
are just tired they're tired of being
lectured about how racist they are
they're tired about being lectured to
check their privilege and whether you
agree with Trump or not I don't agree
with him on things like torture or
surveillance but this is the backlash
you know these people who support Trump
are so condescended towards by the
mainstream media but they had to work
for everything they had these are mainly
quite poor blue-collar workers that are
supporting Trump but they're sick of
being made to feel guilty about who they
are but the establishment still doesn't
recognize that fact and just labels them
racists and bigots they still don't get
it they still don't get what's driving
this phenomenon and it might end up you
know slapping them in the face yeah well
I think it's slapping them in the face
right now so how much of this do you
think is establishment politicians and
just the establishment on both the
Democrats and the Republicans in bed
with the media that they've all gotten
so fat for so long that they've all just
asked terrible questions and no good
follow-ups and they've all just been in
this game for so long that they their
fear of Trump is that he's going to
leave a lot of these guys without a job
a lot of these pundits on TV and all
these people who have professionally
gotten everything wrong for years but
they've had a gig and a lot of these
people I think think well I'm not gonna
have a gig if Trump gets in so they're
they're protecting their own asses more
than anything else well that's
definitely part of it I mean the other
part is you know Trump is self-funded
he's a maverick he might be a rich
bigoted buffoon but he's unpredictable
and the elite the establishment the
political establishment is used to
having not one but two candidates in
every single presidential race that they
control I mean you go back to 2004 you
know Bush and Kerry both skullenbones
members that's you know that's business
as usual for the political elite
somebody like Trump comes along he's a
he's a loose cannon
he's unpredictable they don't know what
he's gonna do I think if he got in power
he would immediately start you know
modder
reading his rhetoric or whatever but
they're scared stiff because it's simply
an unknown quantity and as he said a lot
of you know people in the establishment
who have relied on this status quo for
so long for decades are now petrified
because you know he's come along and
upturn the apple cart people are scared
yeah so do you view this all as just a
big negotiating ploy with him because
you know I was seeing this week he made
this comment that you know maybe Japan
should have nukes and everyone is saying
well then he's gonna start a nuclear
arms race but what he really was saying
was either Japan should be able to
defend itself with nukes because North
Korea is there and China and everything
else or they should pay us to defend
them meaning pay the United States
because we basically have agreements
that we defend them militarily so it's
not that crazy of a proposal that we
should be paid you look you know if you
were celebrity you pay your bodyguard
right so do you think a lot of this is
that he just throws this stuff out there
then gets misquoted you know what I mean
the media runs or that ie wants to start
a nuclear arms race and then people it
even strengthens him more because then
people go wait a minute that wasn't that
crazy of a proposal now they just run
with the banner headline that suits
their agenda as he said if you actually
drill down into what he's saying
sometimes it makes a lot of sense
sometimes he just missed speaks entirely
I mean back a few months ago he
advocates of bringing in Syrian refugees
then within 24 hours completely reversed
his position so it's partly that but
geopolitically from a geopolitical
standpoint Trump is better than anyone
else and definitely Hillary Clinton I
mean they called Trump Islamophobic he's
not the one who voted for a war that
killed a million Muslims you know he's
not the one that supported regime change
in Syria and Libya that led to this
migrant crisis in the first place
Hillary Clinton did he's not the one
who's amping up for World War three with
Russia as every other single GOP
candidate has during the debate so if
you want to talk I mean all this
rhetoric about you know Trump the
world's going to explode the day Trump
gets into office because he's so crazy
and out of control
if you
chillie locket is prior record and what
he's advocating in terms of america's
military role in the world it's the most
peaceful definitely out of all the GOP
candidates indefinitely over and above
hillary clinton who voted for the Iraq
war you know it's funny I was at a very
liberal progressive LA party this
weekend and people were freaking out
over Trump and I kept trying to say to
them guys if you fear Trump if you're a
liberal or a progressive or anyone on
the Left you should fear Ted Cruz far
more than you fear Donald Trump but I
couldn't get people to quite understand
why and I'm sort of amazed by that well
it's because they don't read I mean
that's that's my I guess I guess they
don't read beyond headlines and if you
actually listen to Trump speeches which
you know he rambles on for an hour or so
but if you actually listen to most of
them most of his speeches are devoted to
things like trade deals I mean this is
why people are voting for it it's a
reaction you know to the lost jobs to
the ruined towns in Middle America
because of NAFTA because of these trade
deals that have screwed them over if you
map his supporters it correlates almost
directly with the industry
deindustrialization and despair these
areas of America that have been
completely abandoned completely left to
rot by these trade deals that have
resulted in the great sucking sound of
these jobs leaving America so you know
watch his speeches they a liberal a
progressive will never watch his
speeches it's not mainly about building
the wall it's not mainly about banning
Muslims it's mainly about trade and
that's why he has a lot of support
amongst blue-collar workers because
people's jobs have been shipped abroad
and they're furious about it and that's
mainly a left-wing position to be
complaining about that has been in the
past so that's interesting that most
liberals just aren't aware of the main
body of his actual speech and why people
are attracted to his campaign well
that's like when you know they'll tweet
out they'll say oh look Trump ties are
made in Mexico and they say oh what a
hypocrite he is but that doesn't prove
he's a hypocrite
that shows he's a good businessman he's
used our shitty trade deals that our
politicians have signed to make money
here and he's saying I will change those
deals so people like me won't have to do
that somehow that's lost on all my
liberal friends no matter how many times
I bring that up exactly and also what's
lost on them and if you look at the
lines of people going to these Trump
events which again we've had reports in
Wisconsin this week you know a lot of
asian-americans quite a few black people
in fact back when Rubio was in the race
Trump had more than double the support
from Muslim Americans than every other
GOP candidate combined he set to break
records for black vote to support for a
Republican candidate so again this
narrative that it's just about bigotry
and racism is just surface crap you
delve a little bit below and you have to
understand the wider phenomenon why he
has this support this is about a
complete political revolution this is
about an overthrow of the status quo
Americans are sick of it and now finally
they're putting their vote behind it
whether it be for Trump or Sanders yeah
so let's move away from Trump a little
bit I want to back up to something you
said about Hillary so Hillary in your
eyes because of obviously all the
connections between her husband and the
establishment connections that she's
been involved in this forever from being
a first lady to a senator Secretary of
State and all that she's absolutely who
the establishment wants right do you see
any wiggle room on that Oh now why the
establishment behind Hillary 100% I mean
I went to build a bug in it was Denmark
in 2014 Austria 2015 and even back then
we got the inside leaked from the
Bilderberg Group meeting which is this
conference of 120 influential bankers
politicians academics and even back then
they they had come together and said
Hillary's our pick for 2060 my gonna try
and defund all her competition so years
back Hillary was their pick I mean in
2008 she took the fall for Obama and
that was decided it's a meeting in
Chantilly coincidentally the same
location where the Bilderberg meeting
they can take place back in 2018 so yeah
Hillary's being a shoo-in for a long
time now for the elite so where does
this put Sanders in your mind because
look he wants a lot of the changes you
know ironically Sanders and Trump are
talking about a lot of the same stuff
right they both want to severely change
the power structure change the system
yet their supporters seem to absolutely
hate each other so I suspect you agree
with some of the heart of Sanders just
not the policy I can't bring myself to
agree with somebody who says that red
lines aren't necessarily a bad thing I
mean this idea that Bernie Sanders
supporters if he loses to Hillary which
looks like it's almost certainly going
to happen are then going to go and vote
for Trump because he's the other
anti-establishment option I just don't
buy that because for the very reason you
just said they absolutely hate each
other I don't think many of Bernie
Sanders supporters really jive with his
anti-establishment cred
I think they jive more with this extreme
left-wing social justice warrior Pro
socialist Pro massive welfare state
position which I can't bring myself to
agree with but just from the behavior of
his supporters over the past couple of
months has really turned me off to
anything that Bernie Sanders stands for
unfortunately yeah you know it's really
interesting I don't know that I've ever
felt this way about a candidate and I
don't even know that I could have made
this up but I like him more than I like
the reasons that people are supporting
him I think this is what I was telling
my li na plus a couple weeks ago I think
he himself is a decent guy whether I
disagree with him or not
but the underpinnings of what he's
bringing I think are really dangerous
and that's what I fear and that's a
strange place to feel about a candidate
when you like them but you don't like
what they're sort of bringing along with
them I don't know that I've ever felt
that way before about somebody well no
and it's for the same reason that the
Trump phenomenon has happened I mean
he's not he can't control it he's a
maverick he's unpredictable they
wouldn't be able to buy him off so
whatever his policies which I
fundamentally disagree with he still
represents
two threats of the establishment because
he's an unknown quantity so I mean
that's that's why Sanders has paralleled
the Trump phenomenon but you know as it
the way it looks now he's basically got
no chance so it remains to be seen
what's going to happen to his voters but
I very much doubt they're going to go
over to Trump in the kind of numbers
that people are suggesting right so with
the Sanders people my sense is that a
lot of them really want to just burn the
system down and that's sort of why I
can't get behind them because yeah we
have a lot of problems in America we've
done bad things internationally there's
too much money in politics we need a
fairer economic system or all kinds of
stuff that I can get on board with the
ideas of what he says but there's still
something pretty good here in America
and I think we forget that as Americans
and that's what I fear is that these
people want to actually burn the system
down and I'm afraid if you burn it down
what rises out of those ashes is not
going to be any better or at least the
chances of it being any better are not
very good
well when his supporters are carrying
around hammer and sickle communist flags
and talking about a socialist revolution
I mean that gives me the jitters I mean
you can look at Sanders personally you
know he didn't have a job until he was
40 years old he was basically a bomb
living on the floors of other people's
upon so his personal life style kind of
turns me off towards him as well as he
said the kind of things his supporters
advocate or in many cases a lot worse
than what he's advocating so they want
to tear the system down but they
basically want to replace it with
outright communism a lot of them and
again it goes back to this you know
resist capitalism hashtag that was on
Twitter a couple of months ago these
people are you know they're probably
aged what 20 to 30 they've got no idea
whatsoever of the absolute horror that
communism has wrought on the world over
the last 50 60 years we keep having to
you know have that debate over and over
again and why communism is bad and why
leaving people to their own devices and
building a free-market economy is good
because there's this fundamental
ignorant surrounding capitalism people
think that the system of capitalism
we've got now is free-market capitalism
it isn't it's corporatism right crony
capitalism but they think that that's
free-market capitalism which is why they
go to the extreme other end of the
equation and think that communism is the
solution when history has proven that
it's not we keep having to recycle that
argument over and over again because a
lot of these Millennials just you know
don't know the history right so instead
of detangling some of the crony
capitalism and some of the Wall Street
money and all that stuff which he talks
about which is extremely legit they go
we're going to burn the whole thing down
we're going to become communists which
is crazy all right so a lot of the
Bernie support is obviously mixed with
the black lives matter support and you
know one of the things I've been saying
about the black lives matter movement is
their intentions are good and somehow
what's happened to the movement seems to
have been hijacked or derailed by I
think what you would call far leftists
do you agree with that or do you think
the movement was always that way where
do you see it now where do you see it
going well I mean back in 2013 2014
myself and Infowars were on the
forefront of exposing police brutality I
mean probably 25% of my content every
day was about police brutality now that
that whole narrative has been hijacked
by black lives matter it makes you less
enthusiastic to actually talk about
police brutality the effect that they've
had and the polls show this is massive
support for police departments across
the United States because the tactics
that they engage in are so divisive and
turn ordinary Americans off to such a
degree that now a lot of people simply
would immediately support the police
even in a flagrant case of police
brutality so you know yeah you have to
go back to the founding of black lives
matter obviously a lot of well-meaning
people jumped on board in the first six
months or so but the inspiration behind
black lives matter and this is the woman
that the three female founders of that
trionic group said was their inspiration
was a woman named Assata Shakur now
she's on the FBI's most wanted terrorist
list because she killed a cop in New
Jersey back in the 70s and then fled to
Cuba this is a woman who's you know
black lives matter activists they invoke
her name at nearly every rally
she's a domestic terrorist who left the
Black Panther Party because it wasn't
violent enough she joined the Black
Liberation Army you know this was
another domestic terror group that was
involved in bombings and assassinations
killing police officers so when you have
that kind of guru that inspiration
behind a movement obviously it's going
to tend towards violence you had black
lives matter protesters in New York
walking down the street chanting what do
we want dead cops when do we want them
now that's only going to turn people
away from your movement so it's not an
inclusive movement it's been a divisive
movement since almost the beginning
since just after the first Ferguson
protest and it's only got worse as it's
been hijacked by all these opportunists
and operatives yeah so for you as you
said you guys were ahead on this stuff
and I remember seeing a lot of videos
that you guys were doing where you were
talking about police brutality before it
had really bubbled up into the
mainstream news so it must be extremely
depressing for you as someone that like
is in this and you talk about this you
understand that there was something good
here and as you just laid out that it
has been derailed how do you how do you
get it back to that is it too late is
the is the wave already gone to get it
back to what was right dealing with
legit issues about police brutality well
when the entire movement you know BLM
was founded on this Michael Brown case
the whole hands up don't shoot me and
the media peddled that for what six
months or more the autopsy of course it
turned out that was complete BS he never
had his hands up so they baits all their
grievances on these completely
fraudulent cases and then you have a
case like Eric garner which was a you
know a legitimate
to police brutality which you know we
support the victim in that case but they
tend to base all their grievances on
these ridiculous cases that are
obviously justified use of force by the
police so it's difficult to see how
we're going to get back to a rational
conversation about it when these people
are you know invoking the inspiration
the Guru of the domestic terrorist
they're chanting for dead cops you know
you had people plan to bomb the Ferguson
Police Station you had the cops that
were killed in New York as part of a
black lives matter revenge attack by
Ishmael Brinsley so when it attracts
those kind of extremists I mean at this
point I call it a domestic hate group if
this was a bunch of why Oregon militia
members who were you know chanting Foote
black cops to be killed or black people
to be killed who some of them were
actually planning to do that and whose
ideological inspiration was Timothy
McVeigh for example the media wouldn't
get behind that when we've seen elements
of the media get behind black lives
matter we've seen you know time magus
Time magazine in defense of rioting so
they built this whole grievance industry
it was supported by some elements of the
leftist media and now you've got Hillary
Clinton meeting with black lines meet
leaders back a few months ago saying
she's prepared to change laws for them I
think this is a very you know divisive
destructive movement and it's D
legitimized genuine opposition to police
brutality which was an issue and
continues to be an issue but now people
are so turned off towards that as I said
the polls show that people don't like
black lives matter and now more likely
to support police yeah you know a
perfect example of that would be sort of
what you alluded to which is what
happened in Oregon here what two months
ago when you know the clive in bundy
people they took over basically a vacant
you know lot house office and everyone i
saw all my progressive friends were
screaming about what terrorists they are
domestic terrorists I'm not defending
them they walked into a federal building
even if nobody was there in the door was
unlocked with weapons and I think maybe
one person did die somehow related to it
or something you could correctly
I'm wrong on that but there was such
outrage over that where there was
virtually no violence not defending
everything that they did versus the lack
of outrage when there's actual violence
so everything comes down to race at the
end of the day with the progressives
right well yeah that was a there was a
young guy holed up there in the in the
Wildlife Center right at the end of that
situation who was threatening to kill
himself and it was being broadcast live
on the internet it was trot it was a
tragic situation but on Twitter you had
all the regressive celebrating it
calling him a racist and saying he
should shoot himself in the head
you had lavoy finicum who was in the
vehicle you know with a couple of these
other protesters females traveling
through this FBI roadblock he gets out
of the car he gets gunned down god knows
two dozen times or whatever that was a
shady situation but again as you said a
complete lack of outrage they filled the
car with bullets it's a it's a surprise
that these are the women who were
unarmed and we're not showing any
resistance didn't get slaughtered
themselves but on the left there was no
outrage whatsoever because they weren't
black I think we should treat everybody
who's a victim of police brutality the
same regardless of race but because they
don't do that it turns you know white
middle class America away from their
movement and it prevents us from
becoming truly United in addressing
police brutality yeah I mean that's it
right there there unintended
consequences of what they do actually
drive drive people the other way what
would you say - I have progressive
friends most of them well most I'm own
talk to me anymore but I had progressive
friends that when we when we discuss
this stuff they would say well a certain
amount of violence if you really want
social change a certain amount of
violence is necessary do you buy that at
all or do you think that's just an
excuse because look you're not going to
get headlines if if there isn't a
certain amount of violence right if you
just have peaceful both protests the
media doesn't show up well I believe in
non-violent civil disobedience I mean if
you look at everyone throughout history
who's actually changed society if you
look at you know Gandhi or Martin Luther
King who now the
recives are trying to disavow because he
wasn't inclusive of transgender people
then they don't need to resort to
violence because their cause is powerful
enough where people become a threat to
the establishment when they unite black
people when they unite white people when
they unite people from different
political persuasions they don't become
a threat when they resort to violence
because they can be easily demonized
and dealt with by the state so no I
don't I think that's a terrible idea I
think it's going to be unsuccessful yeah
and it's also directly linked into why
these regressives and now we can get
into the regressives somehow we did 45
minutes we barely said the word
progressive why they label everyone you
me everybody else as bigots and racists
and everything else because they're they
can't control people without splitting
us all down into the little racial
markers or you know this one's oppressed
more than you know as somebody keeps
saying the the oppression Olympics
basically so let's talk about the the
regressive
was your wake up to them at the exact
same time as you sort of woke up to the
social justice warrior stuff or did it
come a little bit after that when you
really saw that there was this group of
people that was was protecting and
pushing this ideology well it probably
correlated you know with the rise of
Isis with these terrorist attacks in
Europe with the migrant crisis and the
fact that we're importing people from
bad cultures and I mean that's the heart
of regressive ISM you know it's
self-proclaimed liberals who defend and
tolerate non liberal ideologies and I
think because at their heart their
cultural relativist right they believe
that all cultures are equal well I don't
believe that I think there are bad
cultures and good cultures I made a
video a few days ago some cultures are
better than others but the heart of
progressivism is this idea of utopianism
so there can't be such a thing as a bad
culture accepting the fact that there
are bad cultures demolishes utopianism
so that's why progressive so-called
progressives can't entertain the fact
that they're bad
cultures even for a second even though
they blatantly are I mean you know when
US troops blew the whistle on how Afghan
police officers were bringing young boys
onto the army base and raping them and
they were told to shut up about it
because that was quote part of their
culture I think that's a bad culture you
know when UNICEF has to do PR campaigns
to educate 600 million Indians half of
their population not to defecate in the
street because it's you know causing
deadly infections and child malnutrition
that's a bad culture we need to call out
bad cultures because I don't think
importing them into the West is
compatible with Western ideals of you
know liberal tolerance but the
regressives can't entertain that for a
second because their cultural relativist
they can't entertain the notion that
some cultures are better than others
which is why in Germany for example
these migrants that came in and you know
started defecating in hot tubs start
masturbating in swimming pools started
raping children in swimming pools one of
the swimming pools in Germany responded
by banning male migrant yeah how did the
regressive left respond to that they
complained they said it was racist they
intimidated they forced the swimming
pool into lifting the ban because again
they can't entertain the notion that
some cultures are worse than others and
that's the heart of you know regressives
it's this utopian idea that everybody's
the same and everybody's equal even
though this is bad behavior that we
shouldn't be accepting and embracing in
the West yeah and there's really no end
to it right that's why this snake will
eventually eat its tail because you know
if you look what happened in Germany you
know right on New Year's with with all
the rapes and all the sexual attacks on
women suddenly all the regressives were
defending basically the perpetrators
they kept saying not all Muslims all
this stuff nobody was saying all Muslims
people are saying the specific people
here who did this
they have these set of values they're
the ones that did it that's what a
rational person would say we didn't say
this is condemning every single person
that believes in this and yet they go to
defend that so they throw women under
the bus so it's like they have their
pecking order and in this case women
came below the migrants because the
migrants are mostly Muslim yes the whole
oppression Olympics idea and you know
when it came out in Cologne it later
emerged that most of the perpetrators
were not newly arrived refugees they
were migrants who had been there for
several years and the regressive
celebrated this right they talked about
yeah oh how dare you demonize the
refugees this was done by migrants okay
so migrants who were supposedly
assimilated
they've been there for years and yet
this is the kind of behavior they're
engaging in and that's something to
celebrate I mean that's again that
shines light on the heart regressive ISM
and as he said you know after every
single terror attack we hear the same
thing again and again don't blame Islam
not all Muslims are terrorists nobody
ever suggested that that's never being
part of the debate they try and frame
the debate so it becomes that because
they can't win when you actually drill
down you know into the statistics and
show that this isn't a tiny minority of
people this is why I bang on about again
and again you know I make videos saying
Islam's not religion of peace get death
threats as a result of it I guess to
prove that it is a religion of peace but
I mean you can look at the statistics
this is not a tiny minority of people
this is a problem within Islam this is
why we need to support the voices of
reform within Islam so pew had a poll
for example the percentage of Muslims
who think that suicide bombings are
justified under some circumstances they
asked Muslims in European countries so
in France 31% of adil Muslims over the
age of 30 think that suicide bombings
are sometimes justified if you look at
young people aged 18 to 29 that goes up
to 42% think that suicide
sometimes justify and it's similar in
you know Spain 22% of adults think the
same Germany 10% and 22% of those aged
18 to 29 think that suicide bombings are
justify you've also got huge numbers of
Muslims throughout Europe in France for
example 27 percent of Muslims aged 18 to
24 support Isis so again this is not a
tiny fringe minority of people 21
percent of Syrians support Isis these
are the people who were bringing in so
is this lie that the Islamophobia
industry upholds that it's just a you
know a tiny fringe minority it isn't and
the facts the stats prove that yeah what
do you think of the word Islamophobia I
assume you're not a fan of the word
itself right because it's an imaginary
word you can't fear a set of ideas you
can fear actions that people might do
and Islam itself says a lot of bad
things about infidels like the two of us
right so it's not an irrational fear to
fear this set of ideas it's just this is
just a made-up word right that doesn't
discount that there might be bigotry
towards Muslim people but the word
itself is a slippery slope right well
it's becoming too changeable with racist
doesn't it I mean at this point the
Islamophobia industry is is bolstered
and exaggerated to such an extent I mean
there are Islamophobic attacks and
they're horrible and we should decry
them but it's presented so those are
anti Muslim attacks right not not
Islamophobic attacks right they're not
afraid of the idea of something they're
they're afraid of the people right yeah
those are basically racist attacks but
if you look at actual hate crimes you
know that they're far outweighed by
anti-semitic attacks for example in in
most Western countries so I think that's
exaggerated we saw that again in
molenbeek
just the other day where the media
reported that a right-wing protester had
run over a Muslim woman later turned out
that it was a Muslim teen from molenbeek
who ran over the Muslim woman so there
are these these fake Islamophobic
attacks there was another one on Wall
Street where a Muslim woman says she was
slash
across the basin Islamophobic attack
turned I was completely made of so again
you know at this point why not own it
why not say yes I am afraid of an
ideology that supports Sharia law that
supports stoning women to death
executing homosexuals killing people who
leave the faith of Islam yes I'm very
afraid of importing those kind of ideas
into the West and when for example 50%
of Muslims of American Muslims support
the right to live under Sharia law in
the United States that's a problem and
I'm going to call attention to that
figure because it's it's way too high
and to call attention to that figure is
not to be Islamophobic it's to be
rightly concerned about these intolerant
beliefs being imported into the West as
they now are in such great numbers so
for people like us that wanna have
honest discussions about this without
bigotry and without hyperbole and I know
it's very hard to do and we don't win
any points for doing this really but for
people like us and I know it's a growing
movement should we start thinking of
Islam more as a political ideology than
a religion because people no matter how
many times we separate ideas verse
people religion verse people people
can't seem to do it they just there's a
certain amount of people they cannot
detangle these two things but I'm
starting to think that if we start
describing these actions as political
actions killing gays not good
unity oppressing women not good if these
were political a political party was
pushing these ideas the left would be
completely against it so is that sort of
how we have to not to give up our
tactics publicly right now but is that
how we have to start focusing on this
argument I think is exactly I mean you
know sam harris Maajid Nawaz they've
outlined the fact that this is not just
jihadis the problem isn't just jihadis
yes you can point to that and say that's
a tiny minority but the main problem is
Islamist you know I agreed with Obama
when he said terrorism is not an
existential threat I mean we're not
going to all be killed by terrorists
it's not going to be such a massive you
know onset of terror
rest attacks that it proves an
existential threat but when you import
these ideas that are incompatible with
Western society then that's a direct to
our quality of life our culture and the
entire underpinnings of Western society
as a free liberal tolerant society so we
have to emphasize that distinction that
there are not just jihadis there are
Islamists I mean look at salah abdeslam
they're in molenbeek in brussels he was
protected yeah four months after the
Paris massacre by his friends and
neighbors okay they're not jihadis they
haven't gone out and slaughtered anybody
but they were protecting a jihadist
because they're Islamists and this is
this is the problem when we get huge
numbers of people moving into Western
societies they create these ghettos they
create centers of power and then Isis
comes out in its manifesto and says
we're going to encourage the creation of
these ghettos in the West to radicalize
these populations to support our cause
then that's a problem I mean you can get
an ak-47 on the streets of Mahlon be
within a few hours for 400 euros that
doesn't just arise out jihadis that's
this whole Islamist support network that
protects salah abdeslam for example so
that's the distinction we need to
emphasize to leftists and regressives
again it's not a tiny minority we have
to include Islamists as part of the
problem and if you include them as part
of the problem the figures show that
it's a de-stressing proportion of people
who support advocate and promote these
intolerant beliefs yeah and I know no
matter how many times we repeat the
difference between jihadists and
Islamists and the average nominal Muslim
somehow that just can't get through to a
certain amount of people but before I
let you go I want to dive into the
immigration thing a little deeper
because you've done a lot on it and when
I've watched some of your videos you
know we really in the mainstream media
in the United States we barely talked
about it I would guess that if you watch
CNN 24 hours today
you wouldn't see one story on it
literally not one minute on it and then
I watch your videos and some other
people and I'll watch them stuff on the
BBC or something like that and I get a
sense that it's a big problem and I get
tons of messages mainly I'm getting a
ton of stuff from Sweden especially
talking about this would you say out of
a ten where where is this thing at right
now I mean is this really as bad as the
videos that you put out it makes it
sound like there's a massive crisis
right now or is some of it overblown is
it different for every country I'm still
struggling to get a hold on it well it's
different for every country that tends
to be a tipping point when a country
goes above for example 6 to 7 percent
Muslim population that's when you get
the no-go areas which the media still
claims is a conspiracy theory I got
changed out of one in molenbeek I can
attest to the fact that it's not so
that's the kind of tipping point I mean
to illustrate this you can look at the
prison populations in these different
European countries so for example
Belgium which of course just suffered
the Brussels attack the Muslim
population is around 6% but the prison
population of Belgium comprises 45%
muslims 45% of the prisoners in belgium
are muslims despite the fact they only
make up 6% of the population you look at
friends 6 to 10% muslim population but
the prison population is 70% muslims
same in spain Muslim population 3.7
percent prison population is 70% Muslim
so obviously something is broken here
and we were getting the create words
seem the creation or more of these
ghettos they don't assimilate but our
political leaders want to bring them in
for their own agenda which is the goal
of importing huge numbers of people from
the third world to vote for bigger
government if you look at polls
conducted amongst Muslims they typically
support expanded welfare state and they
vote once they become citizens for
bigger government so they've placed
Europe security they placed our entire
social cohesion under great
danger in favor of advancing this
political agenda yeah do you think it
was that in the case of like angle of
Merkel do you think it was that
calculated like my sense is that there
was some level of guilt because of the
Holocaust and Germany still is trying to
deal with that that they partly were
trying to do something good here they
brought this I think it's 1.2 or 1.3
million people and and that it is just
crushing the system and creating all
this resentment and a country that has a
tough history with xenophobia it's only
going to get worse and it's hard to
believe that she knowingly did this even
if it was just to get votes which it's
not working right because didn't some of
the right parties just win elections
know that it was the reaction to that I
mean for the past couple of years you've
had a basically a conservative backlash
sweep in Europe that your elections in
2014 proved that so it was a backlash to
that now of course
500,000 migrants who have come into
Germany haven't registered with
authorities so that's going to become a
massive problem but yeah a lot of it was
virtue signaling on steroids right so
you had you know the German Green Party
politician Stephanie von Berg she got up
in front of the German parliament and
said quote our city will change
radically I hold it in twenty thirty
years there will no longer be a German
majority in our city and that's a good
thing yeah so she said that simply as a
way of pissing off the right-wing in
Germany they would bring in these
migrants to displace the German
population so part of it is virtue
signaling on steroids part of it is that
guilt about the Nazis which of course we
have to remember only a minority of the
German population actually supported the
Nazi Party in the 1930s so I would argue
that why would you punish you know
German citizens taxpayers now we've got
Germans being kicked out of social
housing to be replaced by migrants over
1.2 million migrants brought in already
over the past year and again politicians
celebrating the demographic
suicide of that country and it clearly
isn't working because every single day
we have these cases of people being
raped now the primary victims of rape
are Muslim women and girls in these
moment my grant camps but now you see
these reports of you know Afghan
migrants raping boys in swimming pools
and quite frankly I'm sick of seeing it
every single day yeah this is a bad
culture these people aren't being
assimilated if you import huge numbers
of people at breakneck speed with no
clear plan on how to assimilate them
there's going to be bedlam there's going
to be chaos and that's now why top
military chiefs in Sweden in Switzerland
in Norway warning that this could lead
to civil unrest and outright war
basically if it if it continues this way
yeah man I wanted to end with you on a
positive note can we figure out how to
do that where's Europe going to be in 10
years any hope well as I said I mean a
lot of these parties are being voted out
of power and that's been happening for
the past couple of years so there is a
kind of backlash against it you know I'm
all for limited skilled immigration I
think that's healthy for a society but
the way it's going you know 300 thousand
immigrants every year coming into the
United Kingdom we've only got a
population of 60 million and that's
after that that's the number after the
other ones have left so it's going to
become overwhelming it's going to cause
more problems more riots but from a
positive perspective you know my videos
your videos about this are reaching a
huge audience because the media
continually lies about it they don't
point out that 72% of the people coming
in and man these are generally not
families four-fifths of them at one
point weren't even Syrians but the fact
that I can do a video about this and it
gets over a million views proves that
people are thirsty for the truth and we
are shaping the narrative and eventually
the hope is that that will change
government policy by sheer force
oppression
all right well listen that's exactly why
I try to have these conversations and
that's why I like
work you do and you know what here's
what we'll do - for anyone that's
watching this that thinks that anything
that Paul said was conspiratorial or
unfactual tag me on Twitter with them
and we'll talk some of this stuff out
will you make that commitment we'll talk
some of this stuff out with a couple of
the people not everybody I'll do it
you'll do it alright so it's at prison
planet on Twitter and he's doing all
these videos on YouTube and I thank you
guys for watching and Paul you stayed up
late for me so I appreciate it thanks a
lot man
you